ja vielen dank meine damen und herren
wir kommen gerade zurecht
es geht jetzt um den fdp-antrag
nationales info-portal und die erste
rednerin christine aschenberg-dugnus
wird das jetzt vorstellen sie ist von
der fdp management in deutschland
digitalisieren und damit verbessern
ich weiß was sie jetzt sagen werden
impfen ist sache der länder
das ist richtig das wollen wir auch gar
nicht ändern denn in einigen ländern zum
beispiel in meinem heimatbundesland
schleswig-holstein läuft es mit dem
liberalen gesundheitsminister heiner
garg sehr gut in anderen bundesländern
ist das leider nicht so
es geht hier meine damen und herren auch
gar nicht um zuständigkeiten sondern es
geht um einen schnellen weg aus dieser
pandemie und das wollen wir doch hier
alle
die bevölkerung ist es leid dass immer
dann wenn es nicht rund läuft oder etwas
schiefläuft die anderen zuständig und
schuld sind aber das ist ja in dieser
regierung nichts neu ist erst vollmundig
schnelltests zum ersten märz versprechen
und wenn es dann nicht klappt dann sind
halt die länder zuständig für die
bestellung so läuft es nicht meine damen
und herren wir müssen schleunigst dafür
sorgen dass wir nicht sehenden auges von
einem impfstoffmangel uns zu einem
impfstoff bewegen es ist doch beschämend
dass in dem land wo der erste
zugelassene impfstoff entwickelt wurde
bis ende juni erst die hälfte der
bürgerinnen und bürger ein impfangebot
erhalten und das ist noch optimistisch
meine damen und herren ich frage mich
wann die bundesregierung endlich
aufwacht wir sind uns doch alle einig
impfen schnelltests sind der
entscheidende weg raus aus der pandemie
es muss geimpft werden und vor allen
dingen und schnell und rund um die uhr
in israel kann bei ikea und in bars
geimpft werden das liegt natürlich auch
daran dass israel bei der impfstoff
bestellung klüger war als deutschland
und europa als wir noch verhandeln
haben hat israel schon gehandelt
außerdem und das ist der entscheidende
punkt sind länder wie israel bei der
digitalisierung des gesundheitswesens
deutschland meilenweit voraus und wir
wir schlagen uns mit geplatzten
impfterminen die auf zetteln und
excel-tabellen geführt werden
wir schlagen uns mit übriggebliebenen
impfdosen mit ihren professionellen
impftermin management mit ungenutzten
impfdosen und mit unterbrochenen
lieferketten herum das muss ein ende
haben
da fragt man sich warum läuft das bei
uns so langsam warum läuft das bei uns
so bürokratisch unser ziel und das ist
das ziel unseres antrages muss es sein
mit smarten lösungen und schnittstellen
die verteilung der impfstoffe zielgenau
zu optimieren meine damen und herren und
zwar schnell und unbürokratisch
selbstverständlich muss vor ort die
notwendige flexibilität erhalten bleiben
wir wollen keine starren vorgaben aber
ein digitales im portal hilft den
ländern und den landkreisen zu
entscheiden wie viel erst impfstoff sie
verhelfen können ohne einen engpass weil
der zweite impfung zu beraten
unser vorschlag eines nationalteams
portal listet alle verfügbaren
impfstoffe auf steuert die verteilung
auf 11 zentren auf mobile teams in die
arztpraxen und die betriebsärzte damit
ist für jeden akteur ersichtlich wo und
in welcher menge wie viele impfungen pro
tag und woche durchgeführt werden können
kurzum ein digitales nationale sims
management dass schnelles und
zielgenaues impfen ermöglicht meine
damen und herren
aber die bundesregierung hat mal wieder
geschlafen bayern zum beispiel arbeitet
an einem an einer eigenen digitalen
lösung da ist es doch besser einen
bundeseinheitlichen rahmen zur verfügung
zu stellen zu stellen legen sie ein
nationales im portal vor
kommen sie aus ihrer einjährigen
reaktions modus heraus und machen sie
endlich vorausschauende politik ein
nationales im portal hätten sie bereits
im sommer entwickeln können und müssen
wieder mal was die
fdp-bundestagsfraktion hier in
vorleistung gehen vielen dank christine
aschenberg-dugnus hat noch mal
vorgestellt die gesundheitspolitische
sprecherin der fdp den fdp antrag über
den jetzt die bundestagsabgeordneten
hier debattieren nationales im portal
ein forum in einem tool welches die
impftermine koordiniert und verlässlich
vergibt im moment ist es so dass in 16
bundesländern 16 verschiedene wege
bemüht werden rudolf henke jetzt für die
cdu zieht kritischer geist sehr gut weil
man nur aus kritischen geist heraus
situationen verbessert aber zwingender
teil des kritischen geistes ist auch
selbst kritischer geist und wenn ich
verehrte frau genoss aschenberg mich mal
auf den eben genannten schleswig
holsteinischen gesundheitsminister
beziehen darf und wir wissen als union
natürlich dass wir in schleswig holstein
auch mit in der miete drin sind
redaktions netzwerk deutschlands dritter
dritter die astrazeneca im stoff lager
werden immer voller
die impfzentren stehen leer man müsse ja
auch impfdosen für die zweitimpfung
zurückhalten hieß es bislang
entschuldigend von der landesregierung
in schleswig holstein
jetzt wird bekannt cdu
bundesgesundheitsminister jens spahn
riet den ländern schon mitte februar
alle astrazeneca impfdosen so schnell
wie möglich für erste
jungen auszukehren in schleswig-holstein
sorgten aber vor allem computer probleme
des kieler gesundheitsministeriums dafür
dass der impfstoff trotzdem liegen blieb
soweit das redaktions netzwerk
deutschland vor wenigen tagen und
deswegen kritik ist gut aber
selbstkritik ist auch gut und wenn ich
mich umhöre dann finde ich einen
bemerkenswerten kontrast zwischen dem
beschluss den die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz der länder
am 6 november letzten jahres gefasst hat
sechster november mit 16 zu null zu null
einschließlich schleswig-holstein
einschließlich rheinland pfalz
einschließlich auch dem dritten
bundesland in dem die fdp an der
regierung beteiligt es
nordrhein-westfalen und dieser beschluss
lautete ich zitiere das bmg erarbeitet
derzeit zusammen mit der
kassenärztlichen bundesvereinigung auf
basis des bestehenden systems der
terminvergabe der termin servicestellen
der kassenärztlichen vereinigungen ein
standardisiertes modul zur
terminvereinbarung für alle ins zentren
einschließlich mobiler im teams zitat
ende
und was ist dann passiert was ist dann
passiert
die bundesländer wollten dann doch
lieber ihre eigenen wege gehen jedes
bundesland für sich und das gilt für
rheinland pfalz weil es dort so ist das
ein eigenes vom ministerium getragen das
system angewendet wird das gilt wie wir
eben gehört haben für das
gesundheitsministerium in schleswig
holstein und das gilt auch zum beispiel
in baden württemberg wo wir ebenfalls
ein eigenes schon sozialministerium
entwickeltes system haben
herr knigge
[Musik]
herr kollege hängige schaffen wir eine
zwischenfrage der kollegin aus dem berg
dugnus bitte frau kollegin stimmen dass
zb auf sommers eine möglichkeit war für
alle bundesländer dass das jetzt
zögerlich in anspruch genommen wurde
als aber dann die
schnittstellenproblematik gelöst wurde
dh als es ein verbessertes system war
geht es jetzt weiter also sind sie
allgemein dagegen den ländern etwas zur
verfügung zu stellen oder ist es jetzt
nur bei dem antrag der fdp stimmen sie
mir zu dass ihr eigener cdu-chef lasche
gesagt hat dass wir einen
digitalisierungs schuh brauchen stimmen
sie mir zu dass bei der bund länder
konferenz jetzt zum beispiel apps wie
ich sehe nur als beispiel luca
vorangebracht werden muss damit es alle
bundesländer auch mit den
gesundheitsämtern und mit sommers
verbinden können warum machen sie jetzt
hier diese unterschiede das ist wieder
so typisch wir wollen doch lösungen
haben und das ist hier ein etwas wo wir
sagen da muss etwas für die länder zur
verfügung gestellt werden denn sie
wissen doch genau wenn sie jetzt sagen
da läuft etwas schief
dann brauchen wir doch lösungen und dann
fällt verwaltern sie sich doch nicht
diesen lösungen
liebe frau kollegin aschenberg du bist
mein eindruck ist dass sie mit dieser
ausführlichen frage ganz klein bisschen
nur an ganz wenigen bisschen ablenken
weil das thema sommers ist ein eigenes
thema des meldewesens im öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst
wir unterstützen armin laschet total und
komplett mit der ansage dass die
digitalisierung ausgebaut gehört
und dass es zu den großen erkenntnissen
der pandemie gehört wie viele schwächen
wir immer noch im digitalen bereich
ich stimme ihnen komplett zu dass es gut
ist wenn viele gesundheitsämter ihr
schnittstellen problem der meldung in
sommers gelöst bekommen haben das ist
ein wichtiger schritt da haben aber alle
daran mitgearbeitet dass es nicht
parteipolitisch auszubeuten und ich
stimme ihnen auch zu dass die luke
fähigkeiten hat von denen wir großen
nutzen werden ziehen können wenn wir
erleben wie das testen um sich greift
aber das entschuldigt nicht dass sie mit
ihrem antrag monate später sind als der
beschluss den die gmk gefasst hat und
das sich inzwischen die bundesländer und
das ist nicht nur ein problem der fdp
sondern der bundesländer anders
entschieden haben weil ihnen das system
116 117 dann doch nicht länderspezifisch
genug war
weil sie gesagt haben da könnte es zu
modulen kommen die kennen wir noch nicht
so genau und weil dann halt jedes
bundesland sein eigenes system haben
wollte und manchmal auch die kreise und
kreisfreien städte eigene systeme haben
wollten
und deswegen ist das heute verschüttete
milch und ihre idee ist ja jetzt marsch
um kehren zurück und nun wieder
zentralisieren und da sage ich nachdem
die länder halt ihre systeme jetzt
aufgebaut haben aus ihren schwächen
gelernt haben und ich zum beispiel in
meiner heimatregion in der städteregion
aachen aus dem dortigen gesundheitsamt
höre dass sie in der tat jetzt in der
lage sind die terminwünsche super
schnell zu bedienen dass sie für 90
prozent des astra zeneca impfstoffs die
termine für die kommende woche belegt
haben da wäre es ein treppen
jetzt wenn die jetzt sagen würden wir
machen jetzt wieder ein bundesweites im
management neu und liefern allen noch
einmal ein neues system wenn wir
beschleunigen wollen dann dürfen wir uns
an der stelle jetzt nicht in die irre
führen lassen
ich verstehe den ansatz grundsätzlich
ganz gut ich hätte es schön gefunden
wenn das im november so gemacht worden
wäre
aber jetzt kehrt marsch zu sagen wo wir
davor stehen die niedergelassenen ärzte
die betriebsärzte einbeziehen zu können
wo wir in nordrhein westfalen
beispielsweise sich jetzt davor stehen
patzen auszuweisen die den auftrag
erhalten ihre älteren über 80 jährigen
zu hause aufzusuchen und damit die impf
geschwindigkeit zu steigern wo wir in
hamburg erleben dass beispielsweise ein
auftrag an die onkologischen praxen
gegangen ist die krebspatienten jetzt
schon zu impfen
da jetzt wieder mit einem neuen system
noch mal eine warteschleife reinzulegen
das hat mit beschleunigung des imf
geschehens nichts zu tun das hat nur
etwas zu tun mit dem wunsch der fdp vor
zu kommen in diesen debatten was ja auch
begrüßenswert ist weil es uns dann die
gelegenheit gibt zu sagen wie es richtig
ist und da geht es um die beschleunigung
des geschehens da geht es um die
einbeziehung der niedergelassenen
ärztinnen und ärzte in das im geschehen
da geht es darum das angebot der
betriebe und der betriebsärzte zu nutzen
um das im geschehen zu beschleunigen und
wenn wir die ankündigung der dosen sehen
dann wissen wir dass wir für das zweite
quartal mit 76,9 millionen dosen für das
dritte quartal mit fast 100 millionen
dosen rechnen können und deswegen sind
wir sehr gut mit impfstoff versorgt
gerade auch nach der entscheidung
astrazeneca jetzt doch auch für die 65
jährigen und älteren freizugeben und ich
glaube das kann gelingen wir brauchen
dazu jetzt nicht noch mal ein bundes
monstrum
was nach entwickelt wird dafür ist es
leider muss ich sagen zu spät jetzt das
war mal auf den weg weitermachen der
verabredet ist bedanke mich für die
aufmerksamkeit
rudolf henke war das für die union wir
haben gesehen der
bundesgesundheitsminister ist aus der
bundespressekonferenz ihr wieder im
plenum des deutschen bundestages
angekommen zu dieser debatte es geht um
das impfen entschuldigt ein antrag der
fdp die fdp fordert ein nationales im
vorteil und die entwicklung einer
software und der nächste redner kommt
von der afg ullrich
er war präsident und herren seit beginn
von corona wurde die lösung dieser krise
von bundesregierung und teilen der
opposition auf nur eine möglichkeit der
beendigung verengt das heilmittel
impfungen und die bevölkerung wird immer
weiter mit pcr schnell oder an die
gentests auf unbestimmte zeit geklärt
wann fangen sie endlich an ihrer
strategie als wissenschaftliche
grundlagen verstellen und wie wollen sie
wissen welche herdenimmunität inzwischen
erreicht ist
viele bürger brauchen möglicherweise gar
nicht geimpft zu werden dass sie
antikörper entwickelt haben
wir müssen endlich eine wissenschaftlich
basierte strategie entwickeln und das
was die bundesregierung uns anbietet ist
ein unerträgliches chaos jeder gesetz
andrew oder antrag wird dass die gleiche
wacklige wissenschaftliche fundament
gestellt und stur an dieser einen lösung
ausgerichtet und anscheinend versuchen
auch noch kollegen dieses hauses daraus
monetären profit zu schlagen
große teile der bevölkerung sind mehr
als skeptisch gegenüber den analysen
bewertungen und abgeleiteten maßnahmen
deren unmut wird seit dem letzten sommer
aber ignoriert und das jetzt ein herr
lauterbach einer dafür rohner test
locker und einfach für eine schnelle
beendigung dieses zustandes ist ist eine
mehr als durchschaubare ablenkung
wer damals wasserwerfer gegen friedliche
protestanten forderte braucht jetzt
nicht zu denken dass die menschen auf
einmal alles vergessen haben
erinnern sie sich noch an die
schweinegrippe von 2009 2010 für den
damals gelieferten 34 millionen wurden
nur knapp 5,7 millionen dosen verimpft
der rest musste vernichtet werden 28 3
millionen dosen eines unter stoffes
wurden einfach vernichtet warum weil
erstens die bevölkerung nicht gewillt
war als versuchskaninchen benutzt zu
werden und zweitens die getroffenen
quarantänemaßnahmen ausreichten um dem
ausbruch herr zu werden
schweinegrippe heißt des kit 19 geändert
hat sich nichts
hier kommt nun der antrag der fdp ins
spiel auch jetzt ist schon die
impfbereitschaft der bevölkerung nicht
sehr hoch vor allem weise wieder ein
angeblicher runter impfstoff nicht die
versprochene wirkung erzielt und
gleichzeitig häufen sich die meldungen
nach nebenwirkungen problem der
verträglichkeit und sogar todesfällen
die nicht untersucht werden
und warum macht kaiser eine rückruf
übung seines impfstoffes
trotzdem halten sie stur an dieser eine
lösung fest der antrag klingt gut er ist
jedoch nicht die lösung da die pandemie
kurzfristig alleine aus klingen könnte
müssten möglicherweise auch um als
millionen von ungenutzten impfdosen
vernichtet werden
anstatt den nachweis von erregern
sollten wir den nachweis von antikörpern
testen den test nach erregen sollte nur
bei menschen mit schweren sturm gemacht
werden
nicht bei jedem das wäre wesentlich
kostengünstiger längerfristig
aussagefähig und plausibler für den
behörden und es sei nochmals daran
erinnert dass der europarat in der
resolution 320 61 von diesem jahr
festgehalten hat dass es keinen zwang
geben darf und dass niemand aufgrund der
nicht impfung diskriminiert werden darf
es gärt in der bevölkerung das gepäck
des staates ist echt unter dieser
unnötigen last offenen sie die käfige
geben sie den bürgern ihre gesetzlich
verbrieft freiheitsrechte zurück
entdecken sie die wirtschaft von
sanktionen und lassen sie dieses land
wieder ohne masken atmen
vielen dank
[Applaus]
so die maske muss natürlich auch im
deutschen bundestag aufgesetzt werden
zumal ist ja in der vergangenen woche
einen hd abgeordneten gehabt der an
krone erkrankt ist und auch mitglied im
ältestenrat war der ältestenrat musste
dann komplett untersucht werden aber zum
glück hat diese abgeordneten
offensichtlich keine anderen menschen
hier angesteckt nächste rednerin jetzt
martina stammt viebig für die sbb über
die gesprochen so dass wir das heute um
der umgedrehten vorzeichen diskutieren
müssen ja so mancher reibt sich
verwundert die augen aus einer knappheit
an impfstoff ist innerhalb von zwei
wochen ein überfluss an im stoff
geworden stand gestern sind in die
länder knapp neun millionen impfstoff
dosen ausgeliefert worden
das bedeutet dass nach abzug der
zurückgehalten impfdosen noch immer eine
million impfdosen in den kühlschränken
der ländern lagern
aktuell werden rund 200.000 menschen am
tag geimpft und wir erwarten in den
nächsten wochen lieferungen von jeweils
2 millionen impfdosen pro woche wenn man
die zahlen zusammen nimmt man kann man
sich schon mal die berechtigte frage
stellen wieso das ministerium davon
ausgeht dass die zahl der impfdosen erst
im april die im kapazität der zentren
übersteigt mir scheint dass das bereits
jetzt der fall ist
ansonsten
fällt es mir schwer eine erklärung dafür
zu finden weshalb aktuell und ich sage
es noch einmal über eine million
impfdosen in den kühlschränken der
länder liegen
ich kann da noch die vielen bürgerinnen
und bürger verstehen die aktuell kontakt
zu meinem büro aufnehmen und die sich
über die zustände wundern und viele von
ihnen würden gerne an boni sind nicht
kritisiert sind den impfstoff nehmen der
über ist ganz ehrlich ich gute rennen
wenn die zeitnahe im von jetzt schon
nicht hinhaut wie solche situationen
dann aussehen wenn der impfstoff von
johnson johnson noch dazu kommt jetzt
haben sich aus der verwunderung heraus
noch keine probleme von selbst gelöst
was muss jetzt also folgen damit sich
die situation zeitnah entscheidend
verbessert erstens müssen die länder
dafür sorgen dass alle kapazitäten
wirklich ausgeschöpft werden
es darf nicht sein dass beispielsweise
ältere menschen aus mobilitäts gründen
nicht geimpft werden wer nicht zum im
zentrum kommt der muss eben abgeholt
werden
wenn termine abgesagt werden dann muss
ein flexibles terminmanagement geben
dass die neuvergabe der termine
verlässlich regelt es kann eine software
sein wie das etwa in duisburg der fall
ist an softwarelösungen in diesem land
mangelt es nicht
zur not kann ich aber auch lösungen
vorstellen
die analog zur personalaufstockung bei
der kontakt verfolgung in den
gesundheitsämtern funktioniert haben und
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen dann
müssen wir eben wieder die bundeswehr
oder studierende bitten telefonlisten
abzuarbeiten in der situation in der wir
sind muss uns alles recht sein um
einfach das impfen zu erhöhen
jede region ist anders und deshalb
brauchen wir flexible lösungen das
wissen wir alle die zu hause sind weil
wir keinen schimmer
für alle haben wir haben den ländern
genug freiraum gegeben um vor ort diese
individuellen lösungen zu suchen
in vielen regionen glaubt dass auch gut
aber zur wahrheit gehört eben auch dass
mancherorts eine verwaltungs mentalität
zu rasche scheint die ein dynamisches
reagieren auf die aktuellen
herausforderungen er behindert und damit
muss schluss sein
und wenn bereits jetzt abzusehen ist
dass die kapazitäten trotz alledem
weiter nicht ausreichen wovon ich
ausgehe und viele andere
dann darf die lösung auch eine nummer
größer sein und man kann da auch in
nachbarländer punkten
dort gibt es nämlich 24 7 24 stunden 7
tage impfungen und da ist man dann auch
mal in einem stadion wenn es politisch
gewollt ist die viel in diesem land man
muss es nur wollen
zweitens muss jetzt endlich die
ausweitung der impfkampagne oft
niedergelassenen ärzte erfolgen wir
haben in deutschland über 50.000
niedergelassene hausärzte die
schnellstmöglich in die im strategie mit
eingebunden werden müssen und ich
befürchte daher aus befürwortet daher
ausdrücklich dass die aus herz der ab
mitte märz durch die länder beauftragt
werden können und man gleichzeitig an
dass das auch wirklich geschieht wenn
wenn bürokratische kleinkariertheit und
diskussionen über verfügenden digitale
in verfassung seiten lange
dokumentationen oder sonstiges hier zur
weiteren verzögerung führen
das wären dann wäre das für alle
beteiligten peinlich
zum abschluss noch zwei punkte zu den
fdp-antrag wann und in welcher größe die
lieferungen der impfstoffe in die
logistikzentren der länder in den
landesbehörden gehen
ist bekannt die verteilung aus den
logistikzentren in den ländern erfolgt
dann auch nach strategischen
gesichtspunkten welche die länder
festlegen und das ist auch gut so
ich kann mir beim besten willen nicht
vorstellen wie eine bundeseinheitliche
meldeplattform dazu beitragen soll hier
bessere abläufe zu schaffen
es liegt letztendlich in der land- der
ende hand der länder klar mit den
einzelnen städten und landkreisen zu
kommunizieren
ebenfalls schleierhaft es mir wie ein
nationales im portal bei der regionalen
vergabe von impfterminen behilflich sein
soll
ich bin ja froh dass die terminvergabe
in den ländern sich so langsam
eingependelt hat jetzt noch ein system
einzuführen und alle anderen ersetzen zu
wollen bzw dafür zu sorgen dass das
system migration weg ist halte ich auch
vor dem knappen zeit hintergrund für
absolut utopisch
wenn wir eines zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht gebrauchen können dann ist es noch
mehr verwirrung noch mehr bürokratie und
nochmal eins drauf um das gerade anfängt
zu funktionieren jetzt noch mal zu
zerstören
wir lehnen den antrag ab vielen dank für
die aufmerksamkeit
[Applaus]
der bundestag diskutiert über das imb
management einen antrag fiel und der
nächste redner kommt von der lebens
fraktion achim kessler ist obmann im
ausschuss für gesundheit für seine
fraktion
herr präsident sehr geehrte damen sehr
geehrte herren wir bleiben dabei es muss
ein schnellstmögliches angebote für alle
gehen um das virus und seine neuen
varianten einzudämmen zusammen denn
ausreichend möglichkeiten ist dass die
zentrale voraussetzung auch für sichere
öffnung
ich fordere die bundesregierung deshalb
auf endlich alle möglichkeiten
auszuschöpfen die
produktionsmöglichkeiten für impfstoffe
aber auch für schnelltests zu erhöhen
aber zur erfolgreichen bekämpfung der
pandemie reicht es nicht aus alle
menschen in deutschland zu impfen
wir müssen auch an die menschen in den
europäischen nachbarländern denken ja
wir müssen weltweit denken und handeln
sonst warten die menschen in den ländern
des globalen südens noch jahrelang auch
impfstoffe und das virus kommt in form
von varianten zu uns zurück schon jetzt
gibt es varianten des virus gegen die
die vorhandenen impfstoffe nicht
ausreichend schützen
daher müssen jetzt endlich alle
notwendigen maßnahmen ergriffen werden
um die ausweitung von impfungen
voranzutreiben und dadurch dazu gehört
auch ich wiederhole es gerne die
freigabe der lizenzen und den
entsprechenden tanzen
technologietransfer
meine damen und herren bis mitte februar
wurden weltweit 138 millionen impfdosen
verabreicht
über drei viertel davon nämlich 100
millionen in zehn reichen ländern
dagegen haben 130
mit insgesamt 2,5 milliarden menschen
keine einzige dosis erhalten
meine damen und herren das ist eine
himmelschreiende ungerechtigkeit
anfang dieser woche hat die
generalversammlung der
welthandelsorganisation über den antrag
südafrikas und indiens beraten den
patentschutz für corona impfstoffe
auszusetzen solange die pandemie
andauert der antrag wird schon über 100
regierungen und dem generalsekretär der
weltgesundheitsorganisation unterstützt
mit deutschland und den übrigen
eu-ländern wäre die erforderliche zwei
drittel mehrheit möglich ich fordere die
bundesregierung auf ihre blockadehaltung
aufzugeben im interesse der menschen in
den armen ländern aber auch in unserem
eigenen interesse
wir hören aus vielen bundesländern dass
es probleme gibt mit der vergabe von
impftermin unter verteilung der
impfstoffe
die fdp schlägt mit ihrem antrag eine
software gestützte lösung vor um die
lieferung mit der vergabe von impftermin
zu koordinieren
es stimmt wir brauchen bessere
schnittstellen zwischen den
verschiedenen software systemen die die
bundesländer und die bundesregierung
beim imf management nutzen und es sollte
ebenso eine selbstverständlichkeit sein
dass alle impfzentren softwarelösungen
erhalten
aber der antrag der fdp geht wie fast
immer am kern des problems vorbei denn
die probleme der impfzentren bei der
organisation der impfung verweisen auf
ein viel viel grundsätzlicheres problem
nämlich auf den jahrzehntelang starts
abbau den cdu csu spd grüne und fdp in
wechselnden regierungskoalition in den
gemeinsam durchgesetzt haben meine damen
und herren die pandemie zeigt uns die
verheerenden folgen dieser politik
lernen sie daraus
überall fehlt es an personellen
finanziellen und anderen ressourcen auch
und gerade im öffentlichen
gesundheitsdienst und dazu zählen
natürlich dann auch vernünftige
softwarelösung das bestreite ich gar
nicht die koalition rühmt sich dass sie
das keine andere regierung für den
öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst so viel
geld ausgegeben hat meine damen und
herren das stimmt aber zur wahrheit
gehört auch das wird das ist dass das
nur deshalb nötig war
weil sie vorher den gesundheitsdienst
des öffentlichen gesundheitsdienst mit
einer verantwortungslosen
kürzungspolitik ruiniert haben
am elegantesten vielen
gesundheitszentrum überhaupt keine ärzte
mehr
das sind doch untragbare zustände den
gesundheitsdienst zuerst zu zerstören
und sich dann selbst auf die schulter zu
klopfen
in der krise ein teil dieser kürzungen
wieder aufzustocken
das ist wirklich ein starkes stück
glauben sie nur nicht dass die leute das
nicht nur schauen
die fdp hat dazu beigetragen eine
stimmung zu schaffen die öffentliche
behörden und einrichtungen als ursache
allen übels diffamieren
durch die verkleinerung zerlegung und
privatisierung wichtiger bereiche der
öffentlichen daseinsvorsorge wurde die
fähigkeit des staates geschwächt soziale
prozesse demokratisch zu lenken
damit haben sie auch die fähigkeit des
gesundheitssystems geschwächt auf krisen
wir eine pandemie zu reagieren
das zeigt sich jetzt deutlich bei der
impfstoff bestellung und bei der
impfstoff verteilung aber diese probleme
lassen sich nicht mit digitalisierung
allein
ein gut ausgestatteter öffentliche
daseinsvorsorge ein gut ausgestatteter
öffentlicher gesundheitsdienst ist kein
unnötiger ballast sondern das ist der
sinn eines funktionierenden sozialstaat
zurzeit gemäss der antrag der fdp auf
den ersten blick auch scheinen mag
er kassiert doch nur die tatsächlich
probleme der ruf nach digitalisierung
ist eine pseudo lösung solange nicht
zugleich in mehr personal investiert
wird
die notwendigen daten müssen eingegeben
werden sie müssen aus bewertet werden
und vor allem sind es aber menschen die
anschließend handeln und die notwendigen
schritte gehen leider leider war
digitalisierung bisher oft eine
kürzungspolitik durch die hintertür
wir können uns jedoch keine weiteren
kürzungen der öffentlichen
daseinsvorsorge leisten nicht jetzt
nicht nur in meiner familie und auch
nicht in zukunft vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
auch achim kessler hat das problem
angesprochen es wird einfach zu langsam
in deutschland geimpft die organisation
und die verwaltung sind überfordert und
ein riesiges problem in deutschland ist
die unzureichende digitalisierung
deswegen will die fdp ja jetzt eine
eigene software entwickeln lassen und in
einem nationalen im portal bündeln die
nächste rednerin kordula schulz asche
von den bündnisgrünen alle wollen unsere
rechte und unsere freiheiten zurück und
gleichzeitig steigen die
infektionszahlen mit mutationen und wir
haben einen weiteren mpk beschluss der
wie alle seine vorgänger mehr zur
verwirrung als zur problemlösung
beiträgt und warum bei dieser regierung
verweigert einen interdisziplinären
wissenschaftlichen beirat ein pandemie
rat seit monaten und weil wir eine bunte
gegen eine bundesregierung haben die
seit einem jahr nicht in der lage ist
vorausschauend und rechtzeitig zu planen
und zu handeln
es gibt immer noch keine test strategie
stattdessen gibt es seit vorletzter
nacht seit dem dritten vierten märz 20
21 ein arbeitskreis an dem sieben
ministerien beteiligt sind unter der
führung von zwei ministern von dem
mindestens einer wegen des skandals
längst hätte entlassen werden müssen
meine damen und herren ich weiß nicht ob
ihm bewusst ist wie vertrauen die allein
mit dieser einzelnen entscheidung
verspielt haben bei der bis heute kommen
wir werden die pandemie nur in den griff
bekommen denn die menschen eine
perspektive wenn sie vertrauen haben und
wenn die bevölkerung weiter bereit ist
daran mitzuwirken mit den hla regeln
aber wir brauchen auch digitale kontakt
nachverfolgung testen testen testen auch
mit schnell und selbsthass und impfen
kind impfen
und wir brauchen eine regierung die
vorausschauen diese schritte vorbereitet
und deswegen ist es richtig und dringend
sich auch mit der verbesserung der
impfkampagne zu befassen
wir haben die impfzentren und wir haben
die mobilen dev teams wir haben eine
steigende zahl von impfstoffen und
weitere werden hoffentlich bald durch
die immer zugelassen wir haben die
entscheidung der stiko das jetzt auch
mit astra zenica ältere menschen geimpft
werden können
wir haben den mp kabel schluss dass ende
märz april auch in den arztpraxen
endlich mit dem impfen begonnen werden
soll sollen ich sage endlich bei
arztpraxen sehr wohl seit vielen jahren
regelmäßig und routinemäßig impfungen
planen und durchführen und sie können
auch die chronisch kranken
ihre praxen von meine damen und herren
von der fdp dass 19 neue impfpass mag
eine gute idee sein aber sie kommen
damit ein halbes oder mindestens
spätestens vierteljahr zu spät was wir
jetzt brauchen ist doch dass hausärzte
fachärzte und betrieb damit sie
schneller impfen können einen
bundespolitischen rahmen kriegen damit
sie loslegen können das glück unserer
gattung es geht um lieber struktur
es geht um dokumentation und so weiter
und so fort das sind die sachen die
jetzt anstehen die verteilung erfolgt ja
durch die länder
und sobald mehr impfstoff da ist wird es
dann auch los geht aber die
voraussetzung müssen doch hier auf
bundesebene geschaffen werden und da
liegt uns schon wieder nichts vor
jetzt werden sie sagen was ist mit den
impfzentren aber auch da ist das problem
nicht das fehlende internet das
nationale im portal sondern dass ab
mitte märz die impfzentren in der lage
sein müssen
unter volllast tag und nacht impfen zu
können darum geht es die müssen in die
lage versetzt werden sofort loszulegen
mit jedem impfstoff der in diesem
impfzentrum eintrifft und da muss die
bundesregierung die länder unterstützen
pragmatisch und ab sofort meine damen
und herren wir müssen mehr und wir
müssen schneller impfen um die
gesundheit der menschen zu schützen
das über eine millionen dosen astra
zenica auf fall gelegen ist doch ein
skandal aber die gründe hierfür liegen
nicht in vielen regelungen oder in der
logistik sondern sie lägen vor allem im
versagen in der katastrophalen
aufklärung dieser regierung über die
impfstoffe minister sparen wo ist denn
eigentlich die kommunikationskampagne
die breite kampagne die über die
verschiedenen impfstoffe auf klärt über
die vor und nachteile
und ich rede jetzt nicht von den
internetseiten der bzg a sein ich rede
da wo die leute tatsächlich an die
information
herr ankommen wo sie sich täglich sehen
können wir haben hier die idee schon
hauptstadt börse vor acht gesundheit vor
acht wegen meiner auch sie als das
werden sich heute morgen in der
pressekonferenz genannt als kontaktbörse
als ministerielle kontaktbörse egal aber
wir müssen doch endlich dazu kommen dass
die menschen wissen womit sie es zu tun
haben welche probleme es gehen könnte
worauf man achtet was man tun soll wohin
man sich wenn das sind die informationen
die den menschen im moment fehlen und
das ist dieses desaster diese jungs von
beginn an dass sie das verständnis für
die kommunikation in richtung zeitung
einfach nicht verstanden haben und
deswegen wurde ich sie auch wenn
minister nicht nur zu reden sondern tun
sie endlich alles um diese impfkampagne
in tag in den ersten wochen zu
beschleunigen wir grün wir grünen
fordern seit ich glaub seit mai april
mai juni letzten jahres
interdisziplinäre wissenschaftlich
unterlegte maßnahmen die haben wir in
dieser breite immer noch nicht durch ein
pandemie rat ich hab ihnen schon erwähnt
am anfang und einem perspektiv
stufenplan mit klaren
verantwortlichkeiten mit klaren regeln
mit klarer kommunikation die von allen
zu verstehendes von uns allen damit wir
unsere freiheiten und unsere rechte
wieder bekommen könne nicht dafür
[Applaus]
claudia schmidtke cdu/csu direktorin
sehr geehrter herr präsident
sehr geehrte damen und herren von
unseren drei säulen der virus bekämpfen
also den aha regeln den tests und den
impfungen sind die impfungen die
mächtigste waffe sie sind absolut und
abschließend ihre nachhaltige wirkung
ermöglicht uns die vollständige rückkehr
in die normalität und wichtiger nur die
impfung ermöglichen unseren alten
menschen den gebrechlichen den chronisch
kranken endlich wieder ein leben in
sicherheit und ohne angst vor schweren
verläufen durch cupid 19
ich möchte zum vorliegenden antrag der
fdp heute drei punkte feststellen und
auch eine bitte formulieren feststellung
nummer heißt dass wir impfen können das
ist das beste was uns in dieser pandemie
passiert ist das ausgerechnet das jetzt
aber zu den meisten politischen
verwerfungen führt ist anhand der
knappheit der vakzine verständlich aber
es ist auch doppelt ärgerlich
es nimmt uns die zuversicht und bringt
uns zusätzlich gegeneinander auf der
bund könnte jetzt alle vorwürfe die
gegen ihn bei der impfstoff beschaffung
gerichtet waren an die länder zurück
geben die bei der impfung hängen und das
ist sie haben es erwähnt
auch das fdp geführte ministerium und
schleswig-holstein herr henke hat dort
ausführlich darauf hingewiesen
ich werde schön aber deshalb nicht
machen weil wir nur gemeinsam
vorankommen unser ziel muss eine
möglichst breite im
und impfbereitschaft sein und das werden
wir nur erreichen das hat uns das
impfquoten monitoring cosimo gezeigt je
stärker das verantwortungsgefühl für die
gemeinschaft ist die gemeinschaft meine
damen und herren sollte sich jetzt nicht
zerstritten präsentieren sondern
entschlossen die epidemische lage in
deutschland endgültig zu beenden
feststellung nummer zwei natürlich ist
auch dass frauen in ihrem vertrauen in
die impfstoffe entscheidend für die
impfbereitschaft
es ist gut dass die fälschlichen
schlagzeilen von beginn der impfkampagne
mit dem aktien von astrazeneca
mittlerweile weitgehend richtig gestellt
sind
die studie manuskripte von schottland
und england anhalten sogar sehr gute
nachrichten wenn das risiko für über 80
jährige empfänger für eine stationäre
cupid 19 behandlung bereits nach der
ersten dosis um 81 prozent ist das
schlichtweg ein fantastischer impfstoff
frau kollegin genau gesehen frau
kollegin erlauben sie eine zwischenfrage
oder bemerkungen von dr
ach so ja gut dann aus der fdp fraktion
so viel geredet ja oder nein weiter nein
ja wir können uns ja später unterhalten
christi und für diesen fantastischen
impfstoff müssen wir dankbar sein und es
ist gut dass er nun auch für ältere
freigegeben ist
feststellung nummer drei die
impfkampagne ist eine logistische
herausforderung die mehr oder minder gut
umgesetzt wird sie wird erschwert durch
den weiterhin vorhandenen
grundsätzlichen mangel an vakzin weshalb
wir sinnvollerweise eine priorisierung
zugunsten der gefährdeten gruppen
einhalten und in vielen fällen auch
durch unzureichende teilweise sehr
frustrierende terminvergabe
die systeme der länder insofern muss
sich der fdp fraktion völlig recht geben
dass sie dieses problem adressiert und
hierfür auch vorgestern ein für ihre
verhältnisse ungewöhnlich detaillierten
antrag eingebracht hat auch wenn die
quellenangaben jetzt wirklich keinen
wissenschaftlichen wert haben
doch muss ich dem jetzt schon entgegen
halten warum hat die fdp und das hat
auch herr henke und andere gesagt warum
kommen sie jetzt erst auf die idee dass
die zeit terminvergabe zentral erfolgt
durch die länder in denen sie ja auch an
den regierungen beteiligt ist das war
der wunsch von vieren von uns aber
ausgerechnet jetzt jetzt wo es anfängt
zu laufen kommen sie mit diesem antrag
dass die anfangsschwierigkeiten die
immer noch bestehenden schrittweise
abgestellt werden dass dazu gelernt wird
mittlerweile werden fast 200.000
impfungen pro tag vorgenommen die länder
haben 300.000 zugesagt jetzt werden
schrittweise die hausärzte eingebunden
auch bei dieser einbindung hoffe ich
dass die länder die noch keine konzepte
haben von denen lernt die bereits
verarbeitet haben best practice im
föderalismus frau kollegin dass sie noch
mal kurz unterbrechen erlauben sie eine
zwischenfrage oder bemerkungen von maria
klein schmeink nein ich mache mal weiter
meine damen und herren nun ende ich mit
meiner bitten wir alle spüren eine große
und natürlich auch teilweise berechtigte
unzufriedenheit mit dem tempo das die
politik in bund und in den ländern
hierfür den rücken gerade halten muss
ist in ordnung dafür sind wir gewählt
aber ich möchte jetzt einmal ganz klar
denjenigen diejenigen in schutz nehmen
die sich mit viel empathie und
engagement für uns einsetzen in den
verwaltungen in den gesundheitsämtern in
den impfzentren die vielen ehrenamtler
diese pandemie ist nicht nur eine starke
belastung für alle mensch
in unserem land sie ist es auch für die
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter in den
ministerien im bund in den ländern in
den gesundheitsämtern in den
kassenärztlichen vereinigungen es wird
tag und nacht und an den wochenende
arbeitet und nach einem jahr mit hoher
schlagzahl ist auch in den verwaltungen
die kraft teilweise im am ende
es wäre gut wenn wir bei der künftigen
auseinandersetzung darauf achten dass
wir gut und rücksichtsvoll auch in
diesem bereich miteinander umgehen
klar sie bitte zum schluss klar in der
sache und auch klar im dissens wo es
sein muss aber immer mit der achtung
gegenüber denjenigen die im hintergrund
jeden tag für uns viel leisten vielen
vielen dank
doch der claudia schmied wir haben jetzt
zwei kurzinterventionen die lasse ich
hintereinander und sie frau schmidt
gründern darauf antworten mit ein
bisschen länger zeit zuerst die erste
kurzintervention christine aschenberg
muss dass die da jetzt drei schleswig
holstein passion finde ich schon ein
bisschen daneben wir hatten als
schleswig holstein den schnellsten
impfungen waren an zweiter stelle
man hört mich auch mit masken sie können
wenn sie reden können sie die mafia ist
das waren sicherheitsbeamte in sofern
wurden auch die die zweite dosis
zurückgehalten weil das dem dem stand
der wissenschaft entsprach weil man eben
diese zeit nutzen wollte für eine
bessere wirksamkeit der impfung sie sind
ebenfalls schleswig holsteinische
abgeordnete deswegen verwundert es mich
doch sehr dass sie das in ihren
äußerungen nicht mit berücksichtigen und
das spricht doch gerade für eine
digitale lösung wenn es änderungen gibt
dass man zum beispiel sagt man braucht
nur noch eine impfung oder man kann den
den zeitraum zwischen erster und zweiter
impfungen nach hinten schieben dass man
darauf durch smarte lösungen flexibel
reagieren kann das ist doch der sinn
unseres antrages und das haben sie
natürlich überhaupt nicht berücksichtigt
und dass sie dann sagen unser
antrag kommt zu spät also entschuldigung
das ist ja wohl ein treppenwitz wer ist
denn hier in der regierung wer muss denn
für solche lösungen sorgen
das sind doch sie in der regierung und
ich bin ein überaus positiver mensch
deswegen glaube ich immer noch dass die
regierung irgendwann mal aufwacht und
mit eigenen anträgen hierher kommt aber
wenn sie das nicht tun dann ist die
opposition eben gezwungen das selbst zu
machen und dass sie uns dann vorwerfen
es kommt zu spät dass es wirklich eine
unverschämtheit
dank vielen antworten blieben dann jetzt
maria klein schmeink grüne mit ich würde
sie gerne als patientenbeauftragte
ansprechen und ich muss sagen dass ich
sehr vermisst habe dass sie hier am pult
deren perspektive eingenommen hätten und
uns dargelegt hätten was sie unternehmen
um den vielen vielen risikopatientinnen
gruppen die entweder zur priorisierung
gruppe 1 oder zur priorisierung gruppe 2
gehören verzweifelt auf einen termin
warten damit konfrontiert sind dass ihre
kinder jetzt wieder in die schule gehen
also risiken nach hause tragen was sie
dafür tun dass diese patientinnen und
patienten informationen erhalten wie sie
an einen termin kommen wie sie das
zeugnis darüber dass sie zur
risikogruppe erhalten wie sie das
bekommen und wie sie sicherstellen durch
eine kampagne dass diese gruppen
tatsächlich schnellstmöglich dann auch
geimpft werden können das wäre ihre
aufgabe aus meiner sicht es ist sehr
sehr kleinteilig hier über die
regionalen politischen
auseinandersetzungen zu reden sondern es
geht ja darum die perspektive aller
patientinnen und patienten einzunehmen
das ist ihr job den sie extra erhalten
haben hier aus den reihen des
parlamentes und von daher würde ich
erwarten sagen sie uns was unternehmen
sie ganz konkret um diese menschen
besser
und schneller zu impfen vielen dank frau
doktor schmid aschenberg dugnus sie
kommen ja doch noch mal zurück auf
schleswig holstein
ja es ist so es hat sich etwas geändert
mit der impfung sierung und das ist so
dass der bundesgesundheitsminister
sparen die länder darauf hingewiesen hat
mitte februar und dann kann ich ihnen
sagen in kiel wollte man sich aber
absichern und das gerne schriftlich
haben gab selber gespannt da es deshalb
aufgefordert das schreiben zu verfassen
das heißt man hat gewartet bis es ein
schreiben gibt wobei es wirklich schon
kommuniziert war das ist schon sehr
komisch
herr henke hat es ausgeführt es gibt den
gmk beschluss der einstimmig gewesen ist
dann ist es so dass es eine umstellung
der software gegeben hat und deshalb hat
diese software umstellung hat eine woche
gedauert und damit sind 58.000 dosen
liegen geblieben und das ist sehr wohl
ein verschulden des
gesundheitsministeriums also umstellung
auf digitalisierung ist hat dort nicht
so wirklich gut geklappt
die antwort auf ihre frage auch ich bin
abgeordnete und es ging hier um den
antrag der fdp
der sehr konkret gewesen ist und
selbstverständlich bin ich mit vielen
patienten mit vielen die verantwortlich
sind für die im freien folge stets und
ständig in gesprächen ich habe mich
eingesetzt für diejenigen die schwerst
chronisch krank sind damit sie in die
prioritäten weiter vorne kommen es läuft
einfach auch sehr viel arbeit ohne dass
man dort jeden tag darüber redet aber
täglich bin ich damit beschäftigt und
selbstverständlich setze ich mich für
die patientinnen und patienten ein und
mit denen bin ich auch immer einen sehr
guten austausch
vielen dank
kolleginnen nächster redner für die afg
fraktion paul viktor bodó ja und dann
ist mitglied im ausschuss für gesundheit
allerdings hatte die masken nicht
ordentlich auf das hat claudia roth
gerade wurde auch bemängelt
präsidentin meine damen und herren die
bürger haben längst den überblick
verloren
wer wege hin zu werden soll
deutschland 1 weltmeister der
organisation und ordnung scheint unter
bundeskanzlerin merkel im chaos zu
versinken
sie hat uns viel mittlerweile ddr 2.0
installiert aber auch die denn auch die
fdp scheint lange den überblick darüber
verloren zu haben was die aufgabe einer
echten opposition partei ist zu beginn
der krise zeigte stets linientreue als
bundesminister sparen und lehrreicher
wieder von der kanzel aus neue maßnahmen
gebote und angst geprägt haben weil die
anträge wie der antrag zur aufhebung der
hygienische lage denn die hälfte bereits
im mai letzten jahres eingebracht hat
haben sie konsequent abgelehnt und sind
auf der panikwelle mit geräten bisher
eben diesen antrag schlussendlich
kopiert und in die ju nicht selber im
bundestag eingebracht haben meine damen
und herren aber auch erst aus der fdp-
umfragewerte in den keller gerasselt
sind ist ihnen das nicht peinlich
jetzt ist der staat aus anker gefragt so
äußert es sich nicht etwa geld sparen
sondern christian lindner von der
mutmaßlich markt lieber richtige olaf
scholz prozente bazooka hat die fdp wohl
ins staunen gebracht
die kehrtwende kam erst als sie
realisierten dass sie ihre eigene
wählerschaft beraten haben alte
unternehmer der mittelstand und vor
allem den niedergelassenen
ärzte die zu den größten verlierern den
entspannten gesundheitspolitik gehört
und jetzt wollen sie ein nationales in
flotter und eine software entwickeln um
in diesem land endlich einmal eine
hotline funktioniert wann fängt das im
vorjahr ihren zeitplan und so richtig ab
20.25 vorteile tipps und register werden
in deutschland in dieser krise hinaus
aufwendig voranbringen wie die
unrealistischen inzidenz werte der
kanzlerin
meine damen und herren wir brauchen
jetzt pragmatische lösungen die
zulassung von kobe 19 menschen zur
behandlung und das schnelle
unbürokratische hilfen aller
interessenten und das auch im regulären
arztpraxen hören sie auf zu diskutieren
und befreien sie die menschen aus der
geiselhaft vielen dank
so und jetzt sehen wir es noch mal da
muss ich mich korrigieren herr bögerl
hat eine ganz ungewöhnliche maske mit
einem gesicht schild insofern ist das
alles in ordnung was er hier gemacht hat
er hat eine maske auf war schwer zu
erkennen ist für mich zumindest sabine
dittmar jetzt die gesundheitspolitische
sprecherin der spd-bundestagsfraktion
hat als nächste ihr das wort
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen corona geht uns
allen gehörig auf die nerven es ist
anstrengend und kräftezehrend
es ist daher es ist daher nicht nur ein
wirklicher segen sondern ein
gigantischer erfolg unserer wissenschaft
und forschung dass wir mittlerweile drei
hoch wirksame impfstoffe des gegen das
corona virus zur verfügung haben und
nach aktuellen erkenntnissen diese auch
gegen seine mutter werden in foren sind
eine der größten errungenschaften der
modernen medizin und ein wirkungsvolles
mittel um schwere und tödliche
erkrankungen zu verhindern und daher
erfüllt es mich mit großer dankbarkeit
dass sich laut einer neuen forsa umfrage
73 der bürgerinnen bürger sicher und 12
höchstwahrscheinlich gegen korona impfen
lassen wollen von impfmüdigkeit kann
also keine rede sein
und ich bin auch sehr ich bin auch sehr
zuversichtlich dass ich bis zum sommer
jede und jeder impfen lassen kann der
das will
aber meine damen und herren der fdp was
wir jetzt wirklich brauchen ist mehr
schnelligkeit und mehr flexibilität wir
brauchen pragmatische entscheidungen vor
ort den mut diese auch zu verantworten
und umzusetzen
und was er sicherlich was wir sicherlich
nicht brauchen sind entwicklungsaufträge
und ausschreibungen für online-portale
software-lösungen schnittstellen und
eine zentrale verwaltung kolleginnen und
kollegen es ist richtig dass wir zu
anfang bei knappen impfstoffmengen
priorisieren und die menschen mit einer
impfung schützen die vor einer schweren
oder tödlichen krankheitsverlauf betont
sind zwischenzeitlich befinden sich die
meisten bundesländer auch in einen
fließenden übergang zur zweiten
priorisierung von bundesland zu
bundesland ist es allerdings
unterschiedliche mit der registrierung
das ist schon festgestellt wird es ein
ärgernis dass der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz beschluss
nicht umgesetzt worden ist telefonisch
online
einladungsschreiben oder auch die bei
mir direkt in der kommune
das führt zu verunsicherung und ärger
das kann ich nachvollziehen aber jetzt
eine änderung ist einfach zu spät man
hätte das im november sich an seine
eigenen beschlüsse halten müssen
stand heute den kolleginnen und kollegen
dürften knapp 11,5 millionen impfstoff
dosen an die bundesländer ausgeliefert
sein und bis heute aber dann davon auch
über sieben millionen verhilft das heißt
aber auch dass noch vier millionen
impfstoffdosen in kühlschränken und
logistik sendern liegen
und auch wenn die hälfte davon für die
zweitimpfung reserviert ist stellt sich
mir nach wie vor die frage warum sind
nicht schon eine million menschen mehr
in deutschland ticken
und eines ist für mich auch klar das von
der fdp vorgeschlagene im portal wird
dieses dilemma nur bürokratische
verwaltung aber nicht lösen denn das was
wir jetzt brauchen ist mehr drive beim
info ist denn dort wo einlegen in meinen
augen sind da folgende aspekte zu
berücksichtigen wenn ein bestimmter
impfstoff abgelehnt wird was mir
unerklärlich ist wird er
selbstverständlich und sofort in im
berechtigten der nächsten priorität
angeboten
menschen mit chronischer erkrankungen
pflegende angehörige oder auch
beschäftigte in behinderteneinrichtungen
warten sehnlichst darauf und wir wissen
dass der impfstoff und astrazeneca beim
verhindern von schweren
krankheitsverläufen in der gleichen liga
spielt wie die messenger rna impfstoffe
vom bund dec und moderner und
erfreulicherweise hat ja auch gestern
die stiko ihre empfehlungen angepasst
wir müssen zweitens wir müssen die
intervalle zwischen erster und zweiter
im bug auf das zugelassenen maximum aus
denen und wir müssen das zu gestalten
von impfstoff dosen für die zweite
impfung auf eine geringe
sicherheitsreserve einstellt und so
können
in kurzer zeit sehr sehr viele menschen
werfen und das alles sind empfehlungen
die schon seit einigen wochen existieren
und nun auch endlich in den ländern
umgesetzt werden müssen und wir erwarten
im zweiten quartal stand freude und das
ist noch ohne die zu erwarteten
zulassungen von johnson johnson und fuhr
weg über 60 millionen impfstoff dosen
und klar ist auch dass die länder ihre
impfzentren ihre kapazitäten massen
ausbauen müssen die angekündigten
kapazitätssteigerungen auf 300 bis 500
1000 impfungen am tag müssen jetzt auch
zügig erfolgen
und drittens und das ist für mich das
ist für mich ein ganz zentraler punkt
für den erfolg der kampagne ist es jetzt
die haus- und facharztpraxen und auch
die betriebsärzte zügig mit
einzubeziehen und das für die
niedergelassene ärzteschaft das kann
das stellt sie jahr für jahr unter
beweis wenn über innerhalb von wenigen
wochen mehr als 20 millionen menschen
gegen die grippe geimpft werden
ich meine damen und herren bin fest
davon überzeugt dass die einbeziehung
der haus und fachärzte den
entscheidenden unterschied im kampf
gegen korona ausmachen wird
der rest ist dann auch nicht mehr
notwendig da die terminvergabe am
sinnvollsten gerecht endlich gewohnten
praxis erfolgt und der arzt seine
patienten und kann auch vor ort eine
qualifizierte entscheidung zur
priorisierung treffen in mecklenburg
vorpommern und haben wir euch werden
schon selbst schwerpunktpraxen in die
impfkampagne integriert in rheinland
pfalz das übrigens wert wurde mit an der
spitze liegt läuft seit einigen tagen
ein modellprojekt mit hausärzten die
betten eklige patientinnen und patienten
impfen und auch in brandenburg kämpfen
hausärzte im modellprojekt eine
flächendeckende regelhafte und nicht nur
modellhafte einbeziehung unserer
ambulant tätigen ärzte erfordert aber
auch entsprechende regelungen in der
verordnung
und da brauchen wir jetzt lieber
minister sparen wirklich zügig die
angepasste verordnung aus ihrem hause
die fragen zur logistik zur verteilung
natürlich auch zur verfügung aber vor
allem auch die fragen der eigenständigen
daten meldung an das robert koch
institut für den ambulanten bereich
müssen geklärt werden
die haus- und fachärzte stehen in den
startlöchern und warten darauf mit dem
impfen zu bedienen
das alles wird uns schneller und
sicherer ans ziel bringen als die
etablierung eines weiteren
bürokratischen monsters ich danke für
die aufmerksamkeit und bleiben sie
gesund hier noch einmal mit der
feststellung dass die eigenständige
datenmeldungen das rk ii funktionieren
muss das ist ja die sorge die viele
umtreibt auch die fdp die jetzt also
empfiehlt ein eigenes im portal und die
entwicklung einer einheitlichen software
vorgeworfen wird der fdp dass das alles
zu spät kommt aber die fdp hat diesen
vorschlag der das ganze effizienter
machen soll und android man wird das
jetzt noch einmal für die liberalen
ausführen
vor zwei monaten hat der bundesminister
sparen zu beginn der impfkampagne gesagt
und ich zitiere es wird am anfang pro
köln
wir sind bestens vorbereitet
aber jetzt wird es konkret daher sparen
jetzt wird es konkret wann hört das
rücken endlich auf das ist hier die
frage
und frau thema ja sie haben recht ins
geschwindigkeit ist jetzt essentiell
doch impfstoffe aufhalte und langsamer
politische fahrt aufsicht werden
hingegen zu einem crash führen auch bei
der spd
dennoch ist die spd in der regierung und
sie regieren eigentlich mit sie sind mit
dabei das radisson sie immer wieder
niedergelassene ärztinnen und ärzte
betriebsärzte sind schon seit monaten
bereit impfungen durchzuführen
jetzt ist zeit endlich zu planen
weitsichtig nicht kurzsichtig übrigens
herr henkel nach vorne blicken die nach
rückblickend wir bieten die da mal eine
lösung an ein impf portals ein weiteres
werkzeug um die pandemie besser zu
begegnen und ein wort des dankes an
unsere an die service opposition wäre
jetzt eine gute geste sagt er wenn man
erlauben sie eine zwischenphase
bemerkung von verwicklungen von meiner
nachbarn immer gerne
[Musik]
sie haben auch den ausführungen
entnehmen können dass das impfen
natürlich in verantwortung auch der
bundesländer liegt das ist ganz klar
vereinbart und ich hoffe doch sehr oder
frage sie ob sie zur kenntnis genommen
haben dass die regionen jetzt modellhaft
bereits mit arztpraxen und ambulanten
praxen arbeiten dass das alles länder
sind die unter sozialdemokratischer
führung stehen
würden sie bitte stehen bleiben frau
dittmer
danke schön herr ullmann da müsste schon
mit der lupe suchen welche länder das
genau ist denn es gibt auch viele
modelle möglichkeiten und ein modell ist
übrigens auch die digitalisierung und
sie haben es als bürokratischen monster
dargestellt und faxe sind ein
bürokratisches monster und
digitalisierung hilft da besser zu
koordinieren
es geht um merkels sprecher klar und
management und nicht darum welches land
jetzt hier besser ist unter welcher
führung und das ist hier eine gesamt
politische aufgabe der bundesländer wie
auch der bundesregierung und das ist ja
auch meine kritik und unsere kritik
daran sie sind mit in der verantwortung
und sie müssten hier oppositionspartei
innerhalb der regierung das ist immer
sehr überraschend und frau schmitt sie
haben es läuft alles glatt
das stimmt einfach nicht ein beispiel
auch aus england wo menschen älteren
menschen priorität gruppe 1 in der kälte
standen hunderte monatelang minuten lang
bis dann festgestellt worden war ist ein
software fehler und sie sind wieder nach
hause geschickt wollen wir sie nicht
dran waren
oder ein anderes beispiel gestern als
oder gut deutschen großstadt sagt
geregnet stand etwa 70 bis 100 menschen
vor allem im zentrum und warte sind dass
sie geimpft werden das sind
managementfehler und das kann man
natürlich ab stellt durch
digitalisierung und nicht durch wachstum
und excel tabelle und das ist was wir
erreichen wollen
herr sparen
sorgen sie dafür entschuldigen menschen
also das aber dann die letzte
wollen sie eine frage von dr natürlich
von den kollegen aus schleswig holstein
immer gerne
das habe ich nicht lieblings kollegin
ist jetzt keine probleme so jetzt ich
wollte sie lieber kollege ist hier
falsch zitiert haben ich habe nicht
gesagt dass alles rund läuft würde es
mir wünschen weil alles rund lief
und wenn wir alle ein bisschen
freundlicher miteinander ja dass sie
bedanke mich für die korrektur ich freue
mich dass sie auch die gleichen ziele
verfolgen wie die fdp dass wir die
impfkampagne endlich ins rollen bringen
und nach vorne bringen für die menschen
für die bürgerinnen bürger unseres
landes herzlichen dank dafür so und
jetzt kommen sie wieder zu ihrer rede
nur meine rede welche den faden hier
vollständig wahrscheinlich ja die
pandemie weil damen und herren können
wir nur mit klarem hygieneregeln
begegnen wird kontakt verfolgung mit
testungen mit impfungen und das bei
entsprechender management kann das nur
erfolgreich funktionieren aber
management gilt ja nicht nur für
impfungen wie sieht es mit den
schnelltest aus ab montag soll jeder
hier in deutschland die möglichkeit
haben sich einmal ein schnelltest
unterziehen zu lassen
viele kolleginnen kollegen aus der
ärzteschaft aus der bürgerschaft habe
ich darauf angesprochen
viele glauben nicht mehr an dieser
konzepte das vertrauen verschwindet und
das ist ein schlechtes zeichen meine
damen und herren hier müssen wir
vertrauen wieder zurückgewinnen und mit
einem guten management konzept das
voranbringen und jetzt unseren input
eine gute sache wenn jeder sich einmal
pro woche impfen lassen kann bedeutet
dass 320 millionen ds möglichkeiten pro
monat
aber immerhin hat die regierung bisher
150 millionen gesichert reicht gerade
mal für
zwei wochen aber was ist denn mit dem
mann brennt darauf an der stern denn
eine absichtserklärung bei der
diagnostik firmen gibt es nachhaltig
genug schnelltests oder steuer die
bundesregierung auf ihre nächste fiasko
zu diesmal mit den schnelltest hier kann
ich norm fehlen heute noch heute
klarheit zu schaffen was macht die
regierung aber stattdessen die regierung
setzt ein corona task force ein
theoretisch eine gute idee aber was vom
traumpaar jens spahn und andreas scheuer
sie sollen dass beide richten
offensichtlich plant die bundeskanzlerin
in bayern herrenwald ihre vollstes
vertrauen auszusprechen
herzlichen dank wenn du willmann war das
mit einer kleinen spitze gegen zwei
bundesminister die sich jetzt kümmern
sollen um die schnell und selbsttests
aber die impfung die fdp hat ja einen
antrag vorgelegt für ein im portal und
hat vorgeschlagen endlich eine software
zu entwickeln die für alle
gesundheitsämter und für alle ärzte dann
erreichbar ist das ganze also zu bündeln
statt auf 16 verschiedene lösungen zu
setzen erwin rüddel für die union jetzt
der vorsitzende des gesundheitswesens
und ich bin der fdp sehr dankbar dass
sie heute einmal die rolle der länder in
der pandemie bekämpfung in den
mittelpunkt stellt ich habe in den
letzten wochen das ein oder andere mal
kritisiert dass die länder ihren
finanziellen verpflichtungen bei den
hilfsmaßnahmen die der bund auf den weg
bringt unterstützend nicht begleitet
aber heute haben wir die möglichkeit
darüber zu reden und zu diskutieren wo
also die organisatorischen mängel bei
den ländern liegen der bund ist nicht
verantwortlich für telefonhotlines die
nicht funktionieren
der bund ist nicht verantwortlich wenn
menschen der altersgruppe ab 80 keinen
termin bekommen und davon gibt es sehr
viele und der bundes auch nicht dafür
verantwortlich wenn ältere menschen
unnötig verunsichert werden
das liegt auch nicht an den impfzentren
die die kommunen betreiben das machen
die sehr hervorragend das ist ein
deutlich die verantwortung der
landesregierungen und ich komme aus
rheinland pfalz auch in meinem
heimatland machten viele menschen auf
impftermine hier gibt es also ein
impfchaos und soviel ich weiss regiert
in rheinland pfalz die fdp mit und da
könnte man ja auch eine gewisse
hilfestellung der landesregierung geben
und das gleiche gilt auch für die grünen
die hier sehr viel kritisiert haben aber
kennt jemand ein bundesland wo die
grünen nicht mitregieren und oft
zusammen mit der fdp und da wären also
die hilfe hilfestellungen die wir jetzt
hier bekommen ganz hilfreich wenn die
dann auch in den bundesländern ankommen
würden wo man selber verantwortung trägt
[Applaus]
bemerkung aus der fdp fragt nicht ob es
doch da hoffe ich bin dankbar
zwischenfrage zu lassen dank frau
präsidentin
ja sie haben gerade nach einem
bundesland gefragt in dem die grünen
auch mit regierung des baden württemberg
und da komm ich her und ich kann ihnen
sagen dass im portal dort funktioniert
auch nur für 60 jährige
weil darüber können sich ältere menschen
damit eigentlich nicht zurechtfinden wo
ist es auch ein chaos also meine frau
zum beispiel hat sich das lehrerin
angemeldet die wohnt im kreis lörrach
und sollte danach tuttlingen fahren also
das sind über 100 kilometer also dass
auch ein chaos was dort stattfindet dort
ist die grünen natürlich in der
koalition mit der cdu
also das chaos aus aber was ich sie
eigentlich noch fragen wollte wir haben
ja sehr viele astrazeneca impfdosen auf
halde liegen die nicht verimpft werden
im augenblick und wie kann es sein dass
zum beispiel auch in baden württemberg
jetzt im gegensatz zu mecklenburg
vorpommern kein pilotprojekt stattfindet
um die hausärzte einzubinden um diese
impfdosen schnell an den mann zu bringen
und die hausärzte kennen ganz genau
die prioritären verlegen ihren praxen
die menschen dies ganz dringend brauchen
vielen dank also sie bestätigen jahr das
also in den ländern die impfung
organisation und das ist deren
ureigenste aufgabe in der regel nicht
funktionieren und deshalb ist es wichtig
den zweiten aspekt anzusprechen dass wir
so schnell als möglich
dazu kommen müssen dass also in den
arztpraxen geimpft wird weil ich glaube
die entsprechende dynamik werden wir nur
gekommen über die praxen und es ist eben
von der kollegin sabine dittmer
angesprochen worden dass also in
rheinland-pfalz s4 pilot praxen gibt das
heißt also es können
es können alle machen aber es machen
nicht alle und damit es damit dieser
anreiz gegeben wird
es ist ja auch vorgestern in der runde
der ministerpräsidentinnen und
ministerpräsidenten als auftrag erteilt
worden dass man praxen einrichten die
über die länder mit impfstoff versorgt
werden damit also menschen aus der
priorisierung gruppe 1 und 2
entsprechend geimpft werden können also
ich sage es mal
wir geben hier in berlin die richtung
vor dir
anstöße damit die länder endlich agieren
aber wir sind nicht dafür verantwortlich
für die umsetzung und auch die fehler
die die denn dabei der umsetzung machen
und wäre froh wenn alle die die in
ländern mit regieren ihren ländern die
hilfestellung geben die man hier uns
geben will in berlin aber mit der
absicht auch dann entsprechend die
schuld uns hier in berlin zu zuschieben
für dinge für die wir keine
verantwortung tragen weder der minister
noch der bundestag
ich schalte ich halte das angesprochene
tool für überflüssig und wir brauchen
andere lösungen ich habe es gerade
angesprochen und außerdem können wir
nicht so ohne weiteres ein tool auf den
weg bringen
weil dann müssen die länder kompetenzen
abgeben ob sie nun ausfüllen oder nicht
und das glaube ich sind die länder nicht
bereit darum ist das hier nach meiner
meinung auch eine scheindebatte wir
müssen sehen dass wir beim impfen
vorankommen und ich bin der festen
überzeugung wenn man genau hinsieht die
das so schlecht gar nicht aus die
menschen in den alten und pflegeheimen
sind weitestgehend geimpft und das merkt
man auch an den belastungen im
krankenhaus und das merkt man auch an
den todeszahlen in einigen bundesländern
ist die mehrheit der menschen über 80
geimpft das korps ohne risiko der
hochbetagten ist deutlich reduziert
worden
frau widmer hat es eben angesprochen bis
ende der woche haben wir über 11
millionen impfdosen die den ländern zur
verfügung gestellt werden und wir werden
bald erleben das erste impfzentren an
ihre kapazitätsgrenzen kommen und
deshalb müssen wir jetzt neben den
hygieneregeln und den baldigen einsatz
von weiteren schnell person eigenen test
mit allem nachdruck auf eine
zweigleisige im strategie setzen und das
heißt die in zentren sind weiterhin auch
über ostern hinaus das portal für die
priorisierten gruppen parallel muss
durch die impfverordnung gesichert
werden dass die länder auch arztpraxen
für die impfung beauftragen
mit blick auf die rasch steigenden
impfstoffmengen kommt es entscheidend
darauf an die arztpraxen insgesamt
regelhaft in die impfkampagne
einzubinden mit anderen worten wir
müssen demnächst massiv über die praxen
impfen so viel impfstoff raushauen wie
es eben möglich ist und nach ostern
sollten wir perspektivisch ohne strenge
priorisierung über die arztpraxen impfen
sehr hier auch keine probleme die es
über die bewährten logistikstrukturen
des apotheken großhandels zu
organisieren bei der krippe funktioniert
das ja hervorragend und im letzten jahr
sind fast 30 millionen menschen über die
arztpraxen die impf worden ohne dass man
großartig davon etwas gemerkt hat im in
der logistik und in der versorgung wir
brauchen mehr flexibilität wir brauchen
flexibilität mit prinzipien und ich bin
sicher dass die hausärzte da sie ihre
patienten kennen auch das richtige tun
deshalb können wir die priorisierung da
etwas zurückfahren
ich glaube wir haben den richtigen
fahrplan und ich bin mir ziemlich sicher
dass wir es schaffen in bis zum oder im
sommer die pandemie
zu beherrschen heck und dass wir zu
unserem normalen leben zurück kommen
vielen dank vielen dank
vielen dank ersten drittel also einer
kurzintervention hat anja christmann
jetzt eine kurzintervention von anna
christmetten vielen dank herr kollege
ich wollte da gerne nochmal nachhelfen
auf die frage hin was du mit einem
pilotprojekt in hausarztpraxen in baden
württemberg ist das hatten sie nicht so
spezifisch beantwortet und baden
württemberg startet natürlich auch am
montag ein breit angelegtes pilotprojekt
in hausarztpraxen dort wird in den
meisten landkreisen eine hausarztpraxis
zuständig sein für ein pilotprojekt also
baden württemberg die da sehr zügig
voran
das wollte ich hier nochmal darstellen
im übrigen auch bei der zulassung
weiterer gruppen zum beispiel für den
astra zeneca impfstoff da baden
württemberg vorreiter hat als erstes
lehrkräfte auch zugelassen für die
impfung so dass dort es auch wieder
laufen kann und das ist dann leider
nicht so zügig läuft in den sachen wo
der bund auch einfach die
voraussetzungen schaffen muss wie zum
beispiel bei den schnelltests für
baden-württemberg 7 millionen bestellt
hat und jetzt die nachricht kommt die
sind aber leider erst im april gab das
ist natürlich dann schwierig wenn der
bund diese voraussetzungen nicht schafft
deswegen vielleicht auch noch mal meine
frage an sie dass sie den glauben wie
erfolgreich jetzt diese task forster
sein wird um die schnell heiß
problematik zu lösen
herr rödl bitte
also ich bin ja dankbar dass hier so
viele beispiele gebracht werden dass wir
in dem im prozess insgesamt weiter
kommen indem wir uns gegenseitig
informieren und impulse geben und ich
glaube dass wir in diesem wettstreit für
die bürger viel gutes erreichen werden
deshalb habe ich bin ich froh über jedes
projekt das umgesetzt wird weil wir
müssen das gemeinsam machen vielleicht
ist diese debatte auch der impuls und
der anstoß dafür dass es nicht hilft
auch tausenden bürgern wenn wir uns
gegenseitig schuldzuweisungen zu weisen
sondern wir müssen diese herausforderung
diese pandemie die es vorher noch nie
gegeben hat und die wir hoffentlich auch
zu unseren lebzeiten nicht noch mal
erleben wollen dass für die gemeinsam
bewältigen wir sind auf einem guten weg
wir kommen mit dem impfen voran und ich
glaube wenn wir drei monate weiter sind
dann werden wird diese debatte sicher
übrig haben parallel begleitet durch die
test strategien wir haben tests für
viele menschen wird sicher erprobt im
testen weil wir das also schon seit
monaten bei den pflegeeinrichtungen bei
den krankenhäusern im gesundheitssystem
machen
das ist für uns nichts neues und deshalb
wird auch hier bewährt daran gearbeitet
auch mit bewährten kräften und da bin
ich dem minister sehr dankbar dass er
seine kompetenzen einbringt damit wir in
der pandemie weiter nach vorne kommen er
hat großartiges in den letzten monaten
geleistet und wir sollten froh sein dass
er so einen dynamischen fehlen
kreative durchsetzungsstarken minister
haben und da können manche
landesminister rinnen und minister noch
was
dankeschön
tja das wurde offensichtlich claudia
roth dann zu viele witze rednerin
entgegen dieser debatte
zöllner ist selber privat hof
gesundheits und krankenpflegerin das
passt ja ganz gut hier bei der
diskussion ums im portal und die
bewältigung der panel manchmal den
eindruck als hätten wir in unserem land
noch nie geimpft wir haben im letzten
jahr 30 millionen menschen geimpft in
arztpraxen bei der grippe und es hat gut
funktioniert deswegen finde ich diese
debatte insgesamt sehr abstrakt und ich
glaube auch sehr viele mediziner aus der
praxis tun dass das thema der impfdosen
die zurückgelegt wurden das ist
natürlich eine woche betrachtung und wir
müssen natürlich schnell sein wir wollen
sie für impfen aber zb gab es von
unserem bundesgesundheitsministerin
sparen dazu auch schon am 15 februar ein
schreiben dass man eben wo er eben ganz
konkret empfohlen hat beim astra
zinecker impfstoff im februar und märz
vollständig diese impfung für die
erstimpfung zu nutzen und es ist nur ein
beispiel wo wir eben auch als bunt
vorangehen wir wollen leitplanken für
die länder setzen und das haben wir in
diesem fall auch getan und nichts desto
trotz kann ich aber auch verstehen wenn
in der praxis der ein oder andere sagt
ich bin einfach ein stück weit
zurückhaltend und cookies mit der zweite
impfung neu wie die lieferungen laufen
denn wir sind einfach in eine situation
wo wir eine begrenzte menge auch haben
und deswegen bin ich erstmal ganz
grundsätzlich kann ich das an der einen
oder anderen stelle nachvollziehen
nichtsdestotrotz wie gesagt wir haben
eine woche im betrachtung und in der
nächsten woche wird die betrachtung mit
sicherheit schon wieder eine andere sein
als heute wenn die forderung kommt dass
wir so schnell wie möglich in die
arztpraxen sollen
was natürlich der matchwinner ist was
die ganze situation verändern wird davon
bin ich auch fest überzeugt weil es
nämlich die vertrauenspersonen in
unserer gesellschaft sind und ich bin
froh dass wir im niedergelassenen
bereich bei uns so ein hervorragendes
system haben dann muss man eben zum
heutigen zeitpunkt sagen wenn wir es
heute vom fleck weg her organisieren
würden und über den großhandel auch die
verteilung organisieren würde wie es
ganz normal auch bei den
grippeimpfstoffen das der fall wäre dann
wären wir halt bei vier impfungen am tag
für die arztpraxen und deswegen ist es
einfach eine zahl wo ich sag das macht
keinen sinn zum jetzigen zeitpunkt bitte
lasst uns noch die luft haben für die
nächsten zwei drei wochen und dann bin
ich fest davon überzeugt dass wir auch
flächendeckend mit dem 50.000 arztpraxen
die wir in unserem land haben auch gut
vorankommen und da auch eine impfung
flächendeckend organisieren können die
aber daneben auch sinnvoll ist von der
anzahl her die es wird schon
angesprochen die verschiedenen modelle
laufen bei uns in franken zum beispiel
ist es die stadt führt da läuft bei uns
in bayern das modellprojekt aber
natürlich geschaut wird das wenn es dann
losgeht so richtig dass wir dann auch in
den arztpraxen durchstarten können und
ich bin da sehr zuversichtlich insgesamt
ich möchte aber schon sagen der antrag
der fdp es wurde er vielfach
angesprochen ich bin
er ist überholt ja zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt haben die länder ihre portale
aufgebaut ihre edv systeme aufgebaut bei
uns in bayern läuft es bereits in
anderen bundesländern auch und deswegen
kommt dieser antrag einfach ein stück
weit zu spät aber sie ist ein service
opposition und ich bin service union
ich gebe ihnen einfach ein beispiel wie
sie beim nächsten antrag vielleicht das
ganze thema von der anderen seite noch
mal aufräumen können denn die idee
hinter ihrem antrag die ist ja nicht
grundlegend falsch aber wir müssen eben
meiner meinung nach dann stück weit
tiefer einsteigen
meiner meinung nach ist die pandemie
deuten bei dieser pandemie deutlich
hervor gekommen dass wir ein besseres
wissens management brauchen ein wissen
management ist als grundlage für die
politik dient aber eben auch für
jedermann und das eben liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen der fdp nicht nur auf das
impfen beschränkt sein sollte denn da
ist natürlich die frage wo fangen wir an
wo hören wir auf könnten wir nicht auch
noch ein portal für chronische
erkrankungen diabetes kinderkrankheiten
da wird mir schon einiges und ihnen mit
sicherheit auch einfallen und deswegen
bin ich sehr der meinung wenn wir über
zukunft diskutieren wenn wir auch mit
blick in den herbstschauen und es ist
mir ein großes anliegen dass wir schon
darüber diskutieren müssen ob wir nicht
wie in anderen ländern geben auch zb
eine national library of hair is also
eine nationale bibliothek für gesundheit
einrichten
denn wenn wir eins im letzten jahr im
wenn es deutlich geworden ist dass doch
beim thema über das wissen von daten
zahlen und fakten über die
gesundheitssituation in unserem land
dass wir da noch gut nach steuern können
das thema transparenz und das soll eben
auch von so einem portal und so einer
bücherei oder von einer bibliothek von
gesundheit musste ein zentrales thema
einnehmen und transparenz insgesamt im
gesundheitswesen ist für mich auch so
ein matchwinner wo wir wirklich noch
nachsteuern müssen wir haben es zb mit
dem pflege budget getan gewissen
zukünftig wie viel geld für die pflege
in krankenhäuser tatsächlich auch
aufgewendet wird und wir brauchen eben
dieses meiner meinung nach große portal
auch um eben fragen zu beantworten wer
kümmert sich um das richtige wissen zur
richtigen zeit für die richtigen leute
und das hat die pandemie gezeigt denn es
ist schon es ist so dass wenn man in
unternehmen rumpf ragt und sagt wer ist
zuständig für personal finanzen dann
weiß jeder sofort bescheid und wenn die
frage aber kommt wer ist zuständig für
wissen dann sind häufig große
fragezeichen
deswegen ist für mich in eine
investition und gerade im
gesundheitsbereich der umgang mit allen
zahlen daten fakten in die
das wissen eine investition in die
menschen und eine investition in die
zukunft und deswegen lassen sie uns über
so ein portal sprechen das größer ist
und ich freue mich auf die weitere
diskussion zu diesem wichtigen
zukunftsthema vielen vielen dank im
zöllner des zollamts die hier in dieser
debatte eine muntere debatte über den
antrag der fdp eines nationalen in
portals dieser antrag wird jetzt in den
entsprechenden ausschuss in den
gesundheitsausschuss weitergereicht und
auch weiter beraten geben